these are your golden years and you
deserve a chance to enjoy them in a
comfortable nurturing environment on
your terms here at Federal senior living
and hospice we make sure your final
years are active dignified and pretty
much permanent nestled in the heart of
the nation's capital we offer every
resident a fully independent lifestyle
with a staff of over 2 million spread
across hundreds of agencies you're free
to abdicate all of your constitutional
responsibilities to highly incentivized
lobbyists career bureaucrats and college
interns our members enjoy perks that
your constituents can only dream of
including voting privileges custom
Transportation teleprompters handrails
generous compensation packages
speechwriters hordes of lobbyists
countless opportunities for graft and
nepotism and an annual taxpayer-funded
allowance of more than a million dollars
per year take advantage of our luxurious
on-site amenities like restaurants pools
gyms members only elevators and
substantially weakened insider trading
restrictions or maybe you just like to
relax and unwind in your personal
furnace living area away from
constituents microphones and the
uncomfortable truth surrounding your
voting record and declining cognitive
abilities there's no need to worry about
continuity of care as we carefully
gerrymander your District guaranteeing
you'll have a home here for perpetuity
we strive to give our residents the
freedom to enact policies that benefit
their own generation for decades to come
some of our residents may become
disoriented confused forgetful and even
completely out of touch with the world
at Federal Senior Living we honestly
don't give a damn if you have a pulse
you have a vote what better way to spend
your Twilight years than dictating
regulation for highly technical
cutting-edge billion dollar industries
that affect the lives of millions
Federal senior living and hospice we
Value Independence
wait that can't be right
is that oh okay yep that makes sense
wait does it